how do we classify triangles one way in
which they can be classified is the lens
of their sides let's see how so based on
sight the first kind of triangle is a
triangle which has all its sites equal
to each other to show that they are
equal we put the same mark on each of
the sides this tells us that all three
sides are equal such triangles are
called equilateral triangles remember
all sides have to be equal the word by
itself tells you that equi is equal and
lateral is side the other kind of
triangle is a triangle which has two
sides equal set these two sides such
triangles are called isosceles triangles
any two of the three sides can be equal
and the third type of triangle is the
one in which no two sides are equal such
triangles are called scalene triangles
remember the length of each side of the
scalene triangle is different from the
other so this was the classification of
triangles based on sides the other way
in which they can be classified is the
measure of its angles let us review the
topic of angles a bit if an angle is
less than 90 degrees it is called acute
the angle will look something like this
if it equals 90 degrees then it's called
a right angle which will look exactly
like this and if it's greater than 90
degrees then it's called an obtuse angle
this is how it will look here's the good
news
triangles are also classified in a
similar way look at this triangle all
the angles inside are acute any guesses
on what such triangles are called yes
acute triangles now look at this
triangle this angle here is a right
angle
if one angle in a triangle is a right
angle then it's called a right triangle
it's
also referred to as a right-angled
triangle remember just one angle has to
be a right angle for the triangle to be
a right triangle on that note let me ask
you a random Bastion can we have two
right angles in a triangle try making
one in your notebook and you will get
your answer the third kind of triangle
looks a bit like this if you observe
carefully
you will see that just one angle is
obtuse a triangle in which one angle is
obtuse is called an obtuse angle this
angle in the triangle is greater than 90
degrees which makes it obtuse so this
was the basic classification of
triangles to revisit what we have
covered so far please go through the
summary at the end of this video